this is super interesting we've got the
rnc starting tonight
in which overwhelmingly the case for
re-electing donald trump is going to be
made
by his own family members we're going to
be hearing how great donald trump is
from yes his own vice president but also
from his wife
melania trump his kids ivanka don jr
eric and tiffany
and there will be some other speakers
including that couple from st
louis who pointed guns at protesters but
even trump's family isn't unanimously on
board with his re-election you already
know about
marielle trump's devastating book about
him a few weeks ago that's trump's niece
but there is now leaked audio where
donald trump's
own sister marianne trump berry said
that donald trump has no principles
that you can't trust him and that he
lies all the time now this is not some
random person
who doesn't know trump this is his
sister
let's listen to this devastating audio
and marianne trump barry
particularly aghast at the constant lies
from donald trump
this goddamn tweet and the light oh my
god i'm talking to
freely but you know it is the change of
stories a lack of preparation the lying
the holy
but he's appealing to the base what
they're doing with the kids
at the border now right away right
wingers are focusing on
oh but these recordings were made
surreptitiously these these were secret
recordings
now that's true doesn't change anything
and notably
these were done surreptitiously but not
illegally because these recordings were
made in new york which is
a one-party consent state what that
means is that as long as
one party to the conversation knows
there's a recording being made it's
legal now
we can debate the morality of it i'd
argue
that the moral imperative to remove
trump
is such that i'm not going to get bent
out of shape by
legal surreptitious recordings maybe you
disagree with me there that's fine
uh and now this is where it gets super
interesting remember the claim
that trump paid somebody to take his
sats for him
part of this audio includes trump's own
sister saying she has knowledge of that
take a listen to this always
but he was a tough kid right
before before i had any real catholic
roots right
um but he i mean
i didn't get him in but buddy i know he
didn't get him to college
and he and he went to florida for one
year and then he got into university of
pennsylvania i guess he had
somebody to take his and take the exams
no way and
somebody take his entrance exams
oh
so there's once again the claim in what
marianne trump barry
thought was a private conversation it
was recorded by marielle trump
saying trump paid someone to take his
sats
there are more clips let's listen to one
more where marianne barry trump marian
trump barry
recalls a conversation where trump
called to ask her
hey did you see me on fox news and she
said i don't really watch
fox or much tv and trump was incredible
he couldn't believe wait what are you
doing and she explained that she reads
books
take a look at he said did you this
fox news
i said no why not
i said i don't watch much television at
all
pause what do you do
i read pause
what do you read
books
you don't watch fox what to me
that that is just uh to what to me is
just brilliant about these recordings
are two things first of all trump's own
family
sees trump the way we do and what i mean
by that is
they know him privately and still react
in the same way that we react to the
public version of trump
which tells us that privately trump
really is that same person that we see
in public
the unempathetic self-obsessed
narcissistic maniac
it's the same guy now as far as these
recordings
uh changing anything as in terms of
election results i don't think so
you know donald trump's base ignores
anything that they don't like they
probably won't
even hear about this if they do they'll
ignore it
and in reality there's nothing here that
we don't already know
and his base is so cult-like that
i don't think these recordings are
really going to do anything
in terms of hurting his election
re-election chances if you disagree with
me let me know
uh i i don't see it making any real big
impact
maybe the rnc will and that's what i
want to talk about next
this episode is sponsored by bluechew
one of the things i make a priority on
the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda approved
ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night even on a full stomach
since it's chewable
it works twice as fast as a pill
whenever the opportunity
arises blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed
doctors you don't have to go to a
doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discrete package
they're made in the usa and since blue
chew prepares and ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluechew.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
n p-a-k-m-a-n just five dollars shipping
that's b l ue
chew.com promo code pacman
to try it totally free bluechu is the
better cheaper
faster choice and we thank them for
sponsoring the david pakman show